hey everyone welcome back and in this
video i want to give you a clear crisp
framework for getting started as a
freelance web developer in 2021 with
which with this framework i have made
thousands of dollars per month in past
and i want to give it to you for free so
listen up to this video very carefully
if you want to earn money as a developer
all right so we'll be discussing about
five steps in this video how you can
exactly follow them and make money while
freelancing and freelancing is basically
if you don't know what it is it's
working for others online so it could be
a quick job or it could be a long
project as well it could range from as
small as five dollar gig to as big as
thousands of dollars of a single project
so in this video i want to show you a
step-by-step procedure how we can
proceed personally i have used fiverr a
lot back in the days and i have earned a
lot of money and did a lot of orders and
completed a lot of tasks with that i
don't use it now but i used to use it a
lot if you go to my fiverr profile you
can see i've been using it since march
of 2013 and completed although it has
515 reviews but i have done a lot of
work out of fiber as well as freelancer
and um you know not all the people
review your work as well so it's close
to like thousand plus projects freelance
projects so far in my career but yeah
let me just go ahead and give you this
framework which i'm talking about let's
start all right so the first step is
creating your account and setting it up
properly on any freelancing platform now
i'm gonna stick this example with fiverr
because i have used it the most but you
can pretty much take up off work elance
up for disneyland but pretty much any
other platform out there so how does
this work so the way you have to make it
work is once you create an account make
sure you set up your profile photo your
tagline description whatever it is and a
few active gigs very properly because
first of all i would not want to buy
from someone who has an anonymous image
and i don't know who the other person
out there is so make sure you use your
real image a professional one is fine i
mean i just stick with this although
it's not professional worked out fine
for me but you also absolutely want to
set up a gig one single gig which is
your rockstar cake right you can offer a
bunch of services but set up your one
single gig which is your rockstar gig
and at that time i think i created this
years back but i put out a lot of effort
in order to create this portfolio of
work whatever i did so far and um yeah
this was my rockstar gig in the sense
that i actually go ahead and said
whatever i can offer i will offer
through this gig only make sure you
start set the starting price of your gig
to five dollars nothing expensive
because you want to lure in as many
people as many buyers as you can
initially which i'll tell you why that
is the reason all right so once you have
done the first step that is signing up
on fiverr on any other platform and
setting up a few gigs the next step
which you want to do is actually go
ahead and head into something known as a
buyer's section now most of these
platforms do have a buyer's section
which in this case is by request and
what this section is is that it will
list how or what kind of people you know
some people can post request here and
let freelancers reach out to them so
it's like a notice area where people
write their request and you can request
to work with them right so this is
probably the area where you would spend
a lot of your time especially in the
initial days as long as you don't have
some sort of good reputation as well as
no ranking in the fibers algorithm so
make this page make this area your home
and choose it wisely because you get a
limited number of offers per day which
you can offer right so you cannot just
go ahead and you know create an
automated script and do it for every
single gig which you see right here you
have to be very careful in what kind of
projects you choose what kind of gigs
you apply for and um yep that's that's
something you have to be very careful
about now the important thing here is is
to go for the requests which have a low
budget because that's where how you know
that it will be an easier project you
don't want to take up a very complicated
project if you don't know that much tech
so go for projects which have low budget
and also have relatively lower offers
right
so for example this i don't know what's
the difficulty of this work but this guy
is not willing to spend a lot of money
plus not a lot of people have applied
for this so if this works out to be
something which you can do
then this is an absolutely amazing
opportunity for you right because you
will be able to convert this guy do the
work and get a review which is super
critical so make sure you are using this
section very carefully in terms of how
you're trying to approach because as a
new person the only leverage you have is
price
right so you want to go for as
low as possible in the initial days
because you want to break out of the
audience plus don't try to compete with
these 110 people right you will
absolutely have slim to no chance to
getting this offered because there are
just too many people right so you don't
want to compete
competitions for losers my step number
three is make sure you're doing this as
kind of part-time or full-time work
right if you are having a job on the
side and if you want one with
freelancing do it like three to four
hours a day if you are doing it full
time maybe like go six or eight hours a
day why because you get these 10 offers
but a lot of times what you will see is
that out of these 10 maybe three reached
out to you for further communication and
you want to not just do their work but
also convert them first so you have to
work on your sales scale you have to
work on how you communicate with these
people so that will come with experience
and experience requires time so you need
to spend a lot of time on these
freelancing platforms if you want to
understand the end user if you want to
understand the end customer convert
their project into a reality and earn
money and a review from them so don't
take this as a 30 minute or a 10 minute
task per day but in fact get involved in
fact if you want to break out if you
want to start freelancing you have to
get serious this is not easy earning
money with freelancing is easy it
becomes easier after a certain point but
the initial days are very hard so you
have to understand that and you have to
maintain that mentality that in itself
is a huge step that is why this is a
separate step in this video but you have
to understand how this works step number
four and an important step here is you
should focus a lot on the platform which
you're working on that is fiverr in this
case that means you should focus a lot
on making your profile as good as you
can
on fiverr that means getting a lot of
reviews on fiverr don't just create a
gig and then you know try to get review
somewhere else and try to just show it
in your gig that does not matter the
amount of boost fiber will give you if
it sees that your gig is working is not
compared to all the screenshots and
testimonials you are adding in your gig
page right so what you want to do which
i also briefly discussed earlier is that
you want to go for
simple gigs low budget and even try to
go lower than what they have specified
for example this person needs an expert
programmer to create a small app to
check a huge text list of 20 mbs
containing the websites i want something
so this is this is like a scripting task
basic python scripting or javascript
thing right if you know node.js or if
you know python you can pretty much
figure out what api alexa uses and just
run it against a text file or whatever
and he's offering 15 for that that's
fine that's a fair amount but if you can
you should try to get this task for 10
or 5 dollars and let me tell you why
because out of the 18 people which is
not much
most of the people already have applied
it for 15 or above right so it's either
15 or either 20 25 whatever if you can
offer a leverage on the price front
which is like five or ten dollars and if
you explain his improperly like the way
you should send an offer is not like
just a random i can do your work it
should be proper like if their name is
mentioned then you can use that in this
case it's not so you'll probably just
start with hey
i checked your requirement
of
scraping alexa
for ranks in
your text file
in your last text file whatever right so
what you want to do is keep the
conversation very natural started very
natural but make sure that in your
conversation you are able to hint the
person that you have read the message
because trust me i have used fiverr as a
buyer as well and you will be surprised
by the amount of people present on this
platform would just send you i'm
entrusted i would do your work that's it
that's all they do for all the ten
offers and the first thing i do is just
remove their offer as a buyer so what
you want to do is keep the conversation
very natural make sure you deliver the
point that you have read the
requirements
which the sentence does find it's better
if you ask a follow-up question because
you want them to reply that's that's how
you get them get their attention right
you don't want to convert on the first
conversation you don't want to say order
me you probably want to say like you
know ask any question so maybe like do
you have a preference f e r e n c e for
python
node.js or any particular
programming language like this and in
fact i know like this person is not
technical right so they're probably just
gonna reply with do with whatever you
want but still i wanted to ask why
because in this case maybe if they say
like oh okay i'm non-technical and you
know you just create the script you can
upsell them by saying that okay i have
done this but if you want me to i can
also create a simple web ui on this and
that will be then you can convert him
right so then you can say that will be
twenty dollars extra so you got the gig
for five dollars you can set the amount
five here you can say it one day but you
convert it after you know you upsell
after you have got the person because
now this person knows that yes you were
able to create that script yes you are
confident yes you know what you're doing
and this guy would probably make my life
much more easy if i'm able to have a you
know a web app or a url where i can just
upload the script and it will just email
me for example so then you can charge
him 20 25 30 for this project but try to
get these new buyers smoothly try to get
them quickly and efficiently smartly
you know just make sure your
conversation is very formal because you
don't know who the other person is at
the other side of the table right so
leave them with a question leave them
with a hook some sort of thing and they
mostly respond this always works right
so do that and last but not the least
actually go ahead and keep yourself up
skilling on these skills because chances
are if you're trying to take up your
first freelance job you might not have a
lot of experience right and it's fine
it's completely fine to take a freelance
job in development if you just have a
little experience but what you want to
do is number one gain experience from
projects which you're completing here
and number two just keep yourself
upgraded as well with technologies so
let's say if you are taking up web
development gigs here you also want to
create a gig which says i can do your
reactions work or i can do your react
native work or i can do your next chase
work whatever the way the moment you do
that what will happen is that more
opportunities will be present here
because fiverr platform what it does it
takes your gig and then sends you
recommendations according to what your
gig is about so the more gigs you create
on different topics the more
opportunities you will have the more
opportunities you will have the more
shots you can take at bat right of
getting a buyer once you get a buyer the
more chances are that that buyer would
be able to leave a good rating if you
are good enough right and if you get
enough ratings you automatically just
start getting pumped up by the by the
native platform as well fiverr in this
case so in order for this to all happen
the moment you convert your first cake
you have to make sure you complete the
work and you have to make sure you're up
scaling yourself so that you can be
ready for the next part or the next work
or the next challenging thing so make
sure you're consuming content from
anywhere like it could be code damn it
could be youtube it could be whatever
you want to follow but make sure you're
learning about the tech stack you are
using in your freelance world and just
going back into what i had done back in
the days i mean i still did a couple of
orders for some repeated bias last year
but these these people are actually you
know this person contacted me
seven eight years back as well so that's
why i did that but you can see my last
work was in 2018 right so i'm not doing
like freelancing for a very long time
and in fact truly in 2016 because in
2017 and 18 as well i just did a bunch
of photos but in 2016 and 15 you will
see me doing a lot of work right and i
did all of this
uh with the techniques which i mentioned
you and there were a lot of happy buyers
there were a bunch of sad buyers as well
so it does not hurt if as long as you're
learning and as you're able to complete
the work so that's completely fine but
you can see i mean at one point i was
making like thousands of dollars per
month from fiber right so this is an
amazing opportunity and all these icons
you can see these are repeat buyers
right all of these icons you see these
are repeat by assets most of my business
also came from repeat buyers people
purchasing again and again plus of
course i also offloaded some of these
buyers to direct payments like paypal
once we had established trust so that
you know we can work on a longer project
in a much convenient way but yeah i have
done a lot of work and i have shared my
five-step framework and trust me there
is nothing more to it there's no magic
secret or magic formula you have to
follow these are the only four five
things you have to keep in mind creating
a profile making sure you're active on
the platform for hours if not you know
uh
i mean you just have to be active for a
long time put in the work initial work
would be hard but you have to keep
working and keep up skilling yourself
and for the upscaling part here's a
shameless plug for you you can go ahead
and start learning from full stack web
developer learning path on code dam
which consists of basically everything
and anything you will need for
freelancing and you know completing
these initial orders it starts with a
very small subscription amount which you
probably would cover in your first gig
right so just go ahead and start
learning for full stack web development
for free from code down and even if you
want to upgrade to code damn pro the
first month subscription or you know the
monthly subscription of godam is
probably way less than what you will
make enough in the first week of your
freelancing i can assure you that but
yeah that's pretty much it for this
video you can find basically all the
links in the description even for
joining fiverr that is all for this
video if you liked it make sure you like
and subscribe to the channel
share it with your friends who are
trying to get into freelancing and i'm
gonna see you in the next video really
soon
[Music]
you